j'accueille gilbert montagné
[Musique]
oui
bonsoir ou
le monde
bonsoir cette série alors gilbert et
j'ai le père gilbert thierry cadet faire
un tour en plus parce que tu vois rien
non mais moi j'étais con s est tu crois
je sais pas reconnu machin non non a dit
moi sérieux là on a reçu une dépêche afp
jeudi dernier tu vas commencer demain
une grève de la faim au nom des aveugles
baisse et c'est grave en fait j'aurais
aimé venir vous faire marrer mais là je
suis sur la base'' quand même dans le
sens où donc moi j'étais tranquille je
me regardais un film en noir et blanc
vont normal tu veux et puis j'ai eu un
coup de téléphone
non c'est bon j'ai eu un coup de
téléphone de la plus grande association
d'aidé non voyants qui m'ont demandé si
je pouvais les aider parce que il ya un
problème très important sur la nouvelle
loi sur les handicapés
alors je vous vois vous et vous qui êtes
chez vous aujourd'hui cap et qu'ils ont
déjà
non il faut pas que ce soit un sujet qui
paraît chiant parce que ça n'a rien de
chiens du tout il ya six millions et
demi handicapés dieu alors le la loi la
dernière loi était de 75
donc c'est très important que la
nouvelle loi soit en équation avec notre
évolution et avec avec ce qu'on veut
pour le mieux vivre alors le problème
c'est que dans cette loi ici il ya les
acquis les acquis qui sont beaucoup
moins importants finalement que dans
l'ancienne donc si c'est pour une
nouvelle loi
ouais on perd des trucs sa part qu
est-ce qu on perd c'est la question qui
seront perd on perd
les gens par exemple qui touchent une
pension compensatrice pour les aider
dans leur vie de tous les jours
la pension qui sera à verser à ces
gens-là dont je fais partie pas pour la
pension mais parce que je suis handicapé
qui peut petit peu seulement
et bien la pension sera beaucoup moins
importante qu'elle l'est actuellement
donc ça c'est un peu n'importe quoi
quand même connerie effectivement de
faire une nouvelle loi tu vois pour
donner moins d'argent je sais ce qu'on a
expliqué alors deuxième point il demande
à ce que les déficients visuels qui ont
travaillé pendant 30 ans il arrive à 55
ans et puissent partir en retraite avec
leur taux plein monsieur a peint son
plein on veut l'audiovision alors
l'audiovision c'est drôlement poule ce
truc là c'est un d un supplément audio
quand tu regarde un film par exemple tu
regardes à moi aussi je suis à la maison
je regarde un film la suisse et je
regarde un film je vais adorer
l'histoire je peux te raconter
l'histoire d'un lieu et tu me dire au
fait que c'était une telle vue ben je
sais pas parce qu'il n'y a pas le titre
ça s'appelle gilberte sapène
l'audiovision que sur un canal
particulier je vais rien qu'avec le
numérique je dois être facile exactement
finale particulier mais quelqu'un qui
raconte en fait ce qu'on voit sur
l'écran d'un will et présentèrent ajouté
oui ça marche très bien dans certains
pays par rapport à beaucoup de pays
européens
complètement l'audiovision ça fait 3
après après on va s'aimer à les quatre
en ligne et le quatrième point mais pas
des moindres c'est que moi je trouve
qu'il ya à peu près il ya vingt ans que
je dis c'est ça m'énerve parce que je
répète toujours les mêmes choses et
c'est pour ça que je craque et que je me
suis mis aussi avec eux hors dow est
comme on dit en français ouais
le quatrième point c'est que j'en ai un
petit peu marre du fait qu' on soit
obligé quand tu es dans la rue tu as
besoin de d'argent tu as oublié du
tablier de prendre du blé tu arrives à
une distributrice way des à bab al bien
distributeurs automatiques de billets
voilà alors tu dis ah ben c'est bien
comment je commence je la joue là parce
que ça parle pas il n'y a absolument
aucun moyen pour que je puisse m'en
servir entendre aveugle de la
distributrice
excuse moi mais judicaire en train de se
rendre compte tu vois ce que ça doit
être quand tu es aveugle et tu vas un
distributeur de billets bonjour je dit
je vous aime pas ça que j'ai sur mon
riad sa as
[Applaudissements]
voilà oui donc tu sais pas sur quelle
est la tante appui mais on n'a aucun
moyen n'a aucun moyen de savoir ce qui
se passe et aucun moyen de prendre
l'argent alors ça m'est même arrivé moi
d'avoir oublié de prendre du blé est
d'être dans un taxi et de lui dire
écoutez monsieur voulait venir avec moi
le mec je lui donne la carte
il la met dans la machine et puis
évidemment vous julian le code parce que
parce que parce que je peux pas le
machine et ouais donc peut-être faut
juste de l'argent avec aussi parce qu'on
sait et c'est pas possible de supporter
une chose comme ça alors moi je
comprends pas pourquoi la banque de
france n'a jamais bougé à ce sujet là la
banque centrale européenne n'a jamais
bougé à ce sujet là on en panne
impossible on ne manque de pouvoir
fonctionner beaucoup mieux que ça et
attend la distributrice de faim je dis
attention attendez je vous parle à tout
le monde mais juste ce brin ya personne
ils sont tous pareils et la
distributrice de billets mes potes qui
sont sur fauteuil roulant ils peuvent
pas non plus touchés parce que elle est
trop haute
eh oui donc on est tous à la rue avec ça
alors je dis moi je veux pas je ne sais
pas une histoire de droite gauche si
soir la montre qu' on devrait pouvoir
obtenir le consensus politique sur les
solutions à apporter aux handicapés
parce que c'est quand même pas compliqué
et si on n'a pas de contacts six
personnes nous contactent d'ici quelques
heures
je vois pas comment on va pouvoir faire
autrement gilbert de là tu vas tu as
vraiment faire une grève de la faim
absolument mais moi c'est les potes
aveugle qui veulent le faire
ouais et moi je vais être je suis
solidaire parce qu attends je vais pas
dire je suis solidaire avec vous et puis
pour la grève de la faim ben non moi je
me faire le foie gras et machin c'est
possible mais pas la jouer comme ça donc
j'espère qu'on va pas en arriver là
parce que je trouve c'est une ineptie
alors qu'on demande très très peu de
choses on demande simplement
et bonne nouvelle on vous demande pas
d'argent ce soir de l'amour simplement
de l'amour
alors que je vous demande si vous
trouvez que ça a du sens que je viens de
vous dire a envoyé quelques mails à
droite à gauche ça serait pas bête que
les non handicapés soit vraiment
solidaires avec nous parce qu'on est
dans ce monde là tous ensemble c'est ça
l'histoire vraie de l'accident
merci merci à vous merci
[Musique]
les distributeurs de billets à l'audio
vision quand on regarde la télévision
la retraite que des trucs bien grève de
la faim parce qu'il a deux trois kilos à
perdre et il pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu